people quit on their passion because
they're not getting results you quit on
it because you're not getting the
satisfaction of knowing that this thing
is working that you're getting results
that people care that you're making
money that you're growing a business you
love it but you haven't figured out how
to turn into a business yet and too many
people quit because they don't have
enough momentum you have to recognize
that if you love doing this thing and
you quit on it you will regret that
decision for the rest of your life you
have to keep going you have to find a
way to persevere because chances are
you're just not good enough yet and not
good enough as a human you're great as a
human you just don't have the skill set
yet for how to win in the business that
you're trying and i see so many
entrepreneurs just quit and give up too
early they have a deep love a deep
passion for it but they quit because
they're not getting the results and
their family tells them to quit and go
do something safe and logical and
practical and then you end up hating the
rest of your life